what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as returned to our series on how to
kill superheroes in today's video we're
going to be focusing on the most
powerful member of the Lantern cores and
probably the most one of most powerful
heroes at least in general in the DC
Universe the White Lantern Kyle Rayner
now the reason why we're focusing on
Kyle Rayner here is that he has
possessed the white lantern ring the
longest and is the most adept and how to
use it now one of the kicker's with the
white Lantern rings is that when
someone's given one they basically know
how to use it what Kyle Rayner is kind
of like the progenitor of it all I mean
he's really kind of like the main guy
when it comes to the white lantern
mythos and so it seemed right if we were
going to talk about killing a white
Lantern we would pick Halloween plus
he's the most popular so in order to
figure out how to kill one of these
white lanters or kill Kyle Rayner anyway
we have to know what it is that they're
capable of doing so the first thing here
is that as a white Lantern kyle rayner
basically possesses all the powers of
the emotional spectrum meaning that he
can create constructs powered by will
like the green lanterns or fear like the
yellow lanterns he can emit poisonous
blood like the red lanterns he can heal
injuries like the blue lanterns he could
steal the identities of those he's
defeated like Larfleeze the orange
lantern he could force people to feel
loved like the star sapphires and he can
teleport like the indigo lanterns now in
addition to this he also has powers unto
himself
meaning that he has the ability to
create light constructs made of white
energy he can phase through solid
objects he can generate force fields he
can create energy blasts he can make
himself invisible he's capable of
healing he can fly at super speeds and
he can manipulate reality so yeah he's
really powerful now it's also important
to note that the power of the white
lanterns increases as the layer of the
Lantern ring embraces the value of life
in Kyle Rayner at one time even possess
the life equation within the power ring
after passing through the source wall
which is like this barrier that
separates dimensions within the DC
universe now the life equation is
essentially a mathematical equation
proving the value of life as well as the
sum of all the lights in the emotional
spectrum which contains all the lights
of the various colored power rings
however realizing that the life equation
made him too powerful Kyle Rayner
actually split the white lantern ring
into seven individual wings and green
lantern new volumes number 40 and much
like the Infinity Gauntlet I guess you
know after the events of the main of
Gollancz story the rings could be
brought together to create our gets to
restore the power of the life equation
if the need was dire enough and so with
all that in mind the question that we
have to ask here is how do you kill a
being whose power for all intents and
purposes really borderlines or mirrors
the power of God well the first thing we
have to keep in mind is that commoners
powers are not inherent to him but they
are derived from the white power ring
and so it stands to reason that the
easiest way to defeat a white Lantern is
to essentially neutralize his power ring
now one way to achieve this is to drain
the ring of its power which we have seen
happen at various times throughout the
Rings history and DC Comics and Green
Lantern number 133 under the writing of
Marv Wolfman a villain named dr. Polaris
invents a device that he calls a power
absorber which allows him to claim the
power Rings energy for himself later and
Geoff Johns run of the green lantern we
saw a Manhunter robot able to accomplish
the exact same thing
black hand who is one of the Green
Lantern's primary villains also
possesses a device that allows him to
drain the rings of their power now while
these examples all involve a Green
Lantern ring instead of a white Lantern
ring it isn't unreasonable to assume
that a white Lantern ring could be
drained of its energy in much the same
way and once this is accomplished how
Rayner would be just another human being
and would be extremely vulnerable to an
attack now another option for
neutralizing the Rings power is to
interfere with the ring wires ability to
control it by disrupting their focus
through psychic allopathic or any sort
of attack that affects their
concentration now this happened to Kyle
Rayner during the identity crisis event
when Deathstroke was able to break his
concentration but at the same time again
he was also wearing a Green Lantern
power ring which requires exceptional
willpower to operate this may prove to
be more difficult with pal being a white
Lantern since he's now able to exercise
almost total control over each of the
emotions in the emotional spectrum which
is what drew the various colored rings
tomb in the first place however while
this would take someone with a
significant amount of telepathic ability
it would be theoretically possible to
shut off Kyle's Bynes ability to control
the power ring and render him
effectively powerless of course if all
this fails there does exist the option
to simply destroy the power ring or the
power battery required to recharge it
it's important to note here though that
the destructibility of power rings has
been pretty inconsistent throughout the
history of DC Comics but in look
the following the return of Hal Jordan
and green lantern rebirth that the rings
are not indestructible this is evidenced
by Sinestro claiming that he's broken
rings before trying to get too much
power out of them and so this at least
indicates that the rains can be
destroyed
now while certain rings can be destroyed
by other colored rings like the Black
Lantern rings being destroyed by white
lantern rings red lantern rings being
destroyed by blue lantern rings we don't
know of any ring capable of destroying a
white Lantern ring but that doesn't mean
that it can't be done
but the problem that it presents is that
we simply just don't know how to do it
now one characteristic of the power ring
that needs to be mentioned is that the
power is not unlimited
and as the readings wielder uses the
ring it will run out of energy and will
need to be recharged this is
accomplished through a device known as a
power battery now if someone was able to
destroy the power battery or even keep
tile from accessing and recharging his
ring eventually he would simply run out
of power and then he could just be
defeated that way and so in truth when
it comes to the power that the CAO
Rayner possesses as far as I can tell
the only surefire way of being able to
kill him as the white lantern is to
basically ensure that he doesn't have
the ability to charge his own ring the
problem with this is that if he does
charge his ring and it's at 100%
capacity or says national capacity the
power that he has allows them to
approach omnipotence and so at this
point we're really talking about a guy
with a level of power that's almost on
par with God but I know I didn't cover
everything in this there are small
facets here and there with regards to
how to defeat how later especially the
fact that he has proven vulnerable in
the past to telepathy telepathic attacks
and so on so if you guys have
suggestions down below or if you guys
have suggestions in general on how to
kill a white lantern feel free to post a
comment below and let me know because I
know there are a lot of you out there
who are wildly more well-versed in the
Green Lantern mythos than I am honestly
I've always found like the Geoff Johns
uh Lantern mythos to be very very
daunting but I've always found the white
Lantern to be fascinating so if you guys
are new here to comment explain which
you guys should the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob port drop a like
if you guys enjoyed this video
and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]